Shawn what's the most or one of the most
exciting moments you've had as a
filmmaker there have been many exciting
moments over the years but there's this
one small moment I had by myself while
living in New York a few years ago I
used to go down to Chinatown go to Grand
Street and go through all the bootleg
imports and see what I could find from
new Asian cinema because it's sometimes
hard to find you know and I found a copy
of takeout which was nice yeah I felt
like I made it you know my film was
bootlegged over there made it all the
way back back to me and now I'm I'm
purchasing a bootleg of my own film and
I it just was like okay good I the film
got out there now of course I shouldn't
be so happy that my film was bootleg but
at the same time when you're making
these little movies it's just nice to
know that you know it's getting outside
your living room didn't you bought that
copy
I actually went up to the woman at the
counter I'm like this is my this is my
film that's my name okay can I at least
like have this one and she no she didn't
know what I was talking about really if
there's a language barrier but at the
same time I I did pay for it yeah yeah
that's the other exciting moments that's
pretty exciting yeah I mean that's yeah
I I mean the this last I have to say
with tangerine though you may want to
bring back to tangerine tangerine for me
had many exciting moments you know our
premiere at Sundance our you know just
the the days of getting a nice reaction
to the film those 12 days at Sundance
were just they were just a whirlwind but
just recently a week and a half ago when
we were in New York City doing preparing
for the release of the film Kiki and
Maya came to New York and we actually
had Magnolia
made us a float a tangerine float for
the Pride Parade
and it was really just this wonderful
moment where you know Kiki who had not
who's never been outside of Southern
California
you know suddenly experiencing Manhattan
from this elevated point of view in you
you couldn't ask for more than that I
mean I was just so happy that you know
Kiki was there and being able to
experience this wonderful moment and and
I thought I was like in a way like
experiencing the moment through her
because I couldn't imagine seeing
Manhattan that way for the first time
with thousands of people cheering you on
and either side of a Fifth Avenue and
Bret and so it's just an incredible
moment
you